this is Startalk I'm a developmental
behavioral pediatrician okay I think
that qualifies there's an expert a
little bit yeah a little bit work with
hundreds of families affected by autism
and now of course with autism Speaks
fantastic and so what's the goal of
Autism Speaks Autism Speaks is the
biggest science and advocacy
organization for for autism want we want
to make everybody understand autism be
aware of it and do what we can to
improve the lives of people with autism
so now there's a simple question and we
may or may not have time for it what
causes autism that's a great question
yeah I was joking yeah you know what
people say it's a great question it
means they actually don't know the
answer oh that's a great question no I'm
only saying that because of Jenny
McCarthy and the vaccine thing and oh
yeah
autism is a complex disorder and I think
like like most complex disorder is no
psychiatric disorders it's caused by a
combination of genetic vulnerability and
environmental risk factors wow man that
was a greatest way of saying I don't
know that was like wiki page I don't
know this explanation needs some more
sourcing to a wiki info ticket info
speeding ticket so is it possible to
have to have a first onset of autism as
an adult or is it primarily you see it
in kids is that absolutely it's a
neurodevelopmental disorder it starts
very very early may actually start
before birth oh really
there are changes in the brain that we
know are part of development before
birth okay so it has its roots there do
you know what causes autism at all
because certainly a whole lot of people
think they know and they're not vaccine
in the chip vaccinating the children so
what what is the latest research on this
in in general we don't know we we know
some of the factors that increase your
risk for autism there genetic risk
factors there are environmental risk
factors and probably those things
interact with each other so you're
genetically vulnerable then you meet up
with the environmental risk factor boom
and then kick
exactly okay okay so but right now as
far as you know what you can't inherit
it from your parents in most cases no no
which I would have shown up in the data
already it's there there definitely is a
familial influence and that shows in the
genetics if you have a brother let's say
with genetics I'm sorry with autism then
you're much more likely to be diagnosed
yourself okay and so the future of
neuroscience are they on the hot on the
trail on this absolutely very cool
neuroscience going on looking at what is
different in the autism brain both in
terms of the electric waves that are
happening like an fMRI fMRI looking at
resonance right that's so they're
thinking while you're measuring exactly
okay and so we are we've already
identified the part of the brain that is
in facial recognition and and so you
should already know what's not
connecting to those parts of the brain a
big theory is that the the problem in
autism is actually the connections okay
so you have different parts of the brain
that aren't working quite right but
maybe it's because they're not
communicating with the other parts of
the brain that all need not because they
themselves are not functioning as a part
of the brain could be that would be
simple things yeah then thinness then
you just love you think you gotta figure
out how to plug them back working back
in that's it and you're there this is
Startalk